baby backs  I wish you must achieve my powers will  become yours  [Applause]  [Music]  that's crazy right what are your  superpowers swimming for hours dude I  don't even know how to pee in this thing  [Music]  electricity manipulation  hyperspeed I'd like to purchase some of  your finest beer please  [Music]  is Kathy Sparkle fingers no it's not  it's not money that's not my name chosen  one oh you're like a bad guy you really  did the opposite of what a superhero is  supposed to do you're him  you're the hero  you're welcome for not getting robbed  like that  I want you basically 15  [Music]  see that yeah you electrocuted a bus and  who must kill these people and then I  caught it then leap tall buildings in a  single bound  you